[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to GameSpot
I'm pretty excited we are going to be
playing full throttle remastered today
from Double Fine productions I am here
with a man who needs no introduction Tim
Schafer himself thanks for having me
yeah introduction a walk yeah I'll give
you a second one if you want more I'm
like something about my no that was
really great and then of course we have
a Greg rice also from Double Fine he's
here off camera playing full throttle
remastered today professional game
player I'm pretty for the top Rank's
national full throttle remastered
players in the world right now I'm
pretty awful at playing and hosting at
the same time so luckily we have someone
else to do that while we will pull up
gameplay I talk about it kind of up this
releases on April 18th for a ps4 Vita
and PC night um see who loves Vita more
than us yeah yeah that'll be a 1995 game
nice correct and I think correct if I'm
wrong and making any players I was for I
don't know what I was doing I was 14 it
was amazing
leading a projects the first time as a
four-year-old it's gonna tough for me I
have just recently been potty trained
I'm just gonna mention uh yeah so this
is the first six my first title you led
up so I think this is after they go so I
was a baby in some ways so we met it was
my first time and I really liked movies
like Yojimbo and road warrior and the
wild ones old Marlon Brando yeah
inspired by all those but also a friend
of mine who was talking about the fire
bar parking lot and going off the
Sturgis and I was like this sounds like
Pirates like we've made a pirate game
yeah this is what did we say I might
have been I never officially means it
like another yes for those who didn't
play his back in the day or throughout
the years and kind of grows older or 40
or so back then what uh
what kind of game are we looking at this
is a graphic adventure did a lot like
the ten years why was it Lucas oh yeah I
worked on monkey island seeger Macau and
one to ten
there's about story and puzzles where
you would you know walk around exploring
his characters and occasionally solving
puzzles and they had a lot of cutscenes
a narrative and this one we really were
pushing that like storytelling with like
cinematic seems like this one where the
intro is you know meant to really get
you the moves playing the game again
speaking of a beta tentacle and
remasters right this is what number of
remasters is that Double Fine's kind of
brought into the sea I'm switching back
tricks like switching back live oh
that's the only new remastered art and
that's what you look like
we had a paint like 15 thousand frames
animation and so they actually have to
add for HD you a bunch on the sides I
really like when remasters do that so
you can actually fully appreciate how
much better it looks and without the you
know Rose tinted glasses of thinking
maybe in 95 it looked better than I
remember but yeah it shows you how much
better it looks I feel like you it's a
trust thing with the players because I
feel like well I put the special edition
because I was aiming for and I was like
I hope they don't mess up my gallon and
when I went to play it I think I'm gonna
play the original mode I start playing
it that way and it was exactly the
pixel-by-pixel but just like how I
played it and then after a few minutes
of it but I'm gonna tell them you are
just because the jaggies cut my eyes
yeah hurt they hurt to watch so it's
beautiful now it's it's paint it up but
it still I think looks in some ways just
like the original in that it looks just
like what your mind remembers how you
remember their woman about you but like
how one it was normal for normal first
day your your ten-year-old arose yeah
might have liked because your don't
remember you know
things were being met and so we left
that mode and you see like I mean some
people might prefer yeah but
about uh is voice acting is that the
original or did you work at people okay
yeah a lot of the voice actors have
passed away since then we're all here
adieu please Ben throttle and pants they
passed away but we went and found the
original on a like that place for them
and we ended them so that we can have
the uncompressed voice but a lot of back
then are we trying to fit on the cd-rom
or you before I got a floppy disk we
compress it and people's like there s is
a certain certain sound sound would be
like weird if you ever hear like old
games that weird kissing sound so we
uncompressed all that so they sound you
can hear the richness of Conrad's voice
we need those bends deep growly voice
and similarly with the music we've got
the old Keith Carl awesome Don jackals
we got his reel-to-reel tapes okay
awesome and and copy that remixed it and
we put it in stereo and it's all sounds
amazing but you can hear the old stuff
to be put back with you sheriff Daniels
which is actually louder in some spots
because the only way they can make it
sound like rock and roll is like crank
it to hurt your little speakers computer
so I was full throttle the next one you
wanted to really master after you do the
you know like Grim Fandango and data
tentacles we're kind of building up to
it this said the most frames animation
you know grim used 3ds so it had had
some movies but we weren't changing
those movies because they were rendered
with a high res this one had older
movies that need to be painted like
frame by frame you can see all that like
everybody sees all that it was that work
to do that but we knew it'd be this is
just the most time-consuming most
expensive one so we're kind of building
up to it and it was a big one but they
did a really great job with it okay
it's like stylistically it looks like
you're playing like rock band and
missing a note or just goes into the bag
on the bad mode and that comes back you
get back on track and everybody audience
is better didn't want to change any of
the voices cuz they you know we want it
we see it as like respecting the old
work but doesn't present
they're doing both but you know this
kind of game is fun because remasters
because a lot of people hadn't played
the adventure right and I think we went
to this whole thing where that was the
only way we could think to do certain
interactions back in the early nineties
oh boy and click adventures are the only
ways they they're the billions had the
most story in the most like fidelity
like they had the most pretty art and
music and stuff and games kind of caught
up with them here initially so you can
play a lot of games to have that stuff
now but but now that we have a whole
bunch of different ways to tell stories
and stuff I think people have gone back
to look at it's too cool now you kind of
enjoying graphic images for what they
were which is a way of like interacting
with a story and solving puzzles that
moves your own pace so you don't usually
have to worry about getting shot in the
head scratch your head I'm just gonna
wander around think about stuff and take
a break from it and come back and solve
puzzles it's kind of zen-like
narrative experience sure yeah I mean
over the years Double Fine's done a lot
of different genres right yeah but I
mean between like brutal legend costume
quests you know broken age but you see
any like roots of future games in full
throttle or is it kind of just like you
can kind of always see that Double Fine
signature style I mean there's good
common threads that have been think
there's interested me a lot like hot
rods I've always liked there's always
some sort of hot rod in the game that
may go Grim Fandango has the room the
bone and you know and this you know just
loved I really love the road warrior and
before I made this and I still like that
movie and despite the low camera angles
or madly original Mad Max just like you
know following the right on this fender
you know yes that does kind of crazy I
was walking in Potrero Hill and this is
a Hells Angels nest where there was back
then the dog patch and they're just back
him down around the street didn't have a
helmet on he just was wearing like a
flannel shirt is flapping and he went to
the end of this cul-de-sac and then went
up on the curb and went over it's
pedestrian walkway over the freeway
do a wheelie I'm like right in front of
me like he and he never stops I feel
like I have those in a different like a
different world like a different set of
society or rules than me that he doesn't
care and doesn't care
my rules and my sidewalk or my just yeah
and I was like so I kind of romanticize
it a lot like like the management
LucasArts like we can't make a game
about bikers because gonna be like but
murder and drugs and yeah sure but this
is a little more romanticized version
though yeah that's more like like like
wild one Marlon Brando era less like
hunter s Thompson kind of stuff I did
read that book yeah it's good I read it
in like every chapters like we can't do
that we can't do that nope looking for
inspiration and then you shut it quickly
that's a great book yeah yeah physical
box people chatting music box
he's gone right so tricky games yeah
yeah I mean I think we're asking and I
got two types of questions online
through Twitter earlier that we can you
know reference later on during like a
Q&A herb and whatnot but I mean it's
interesting to look at brutal legend and
stylistically right was that influenced
by this a lot it was similar interesting
like obviously heavy metal music and
pipes like yeah you know I went down to
add more pipes like been spiking pipes
and all that but you know the Drude plow
has a bunch of pipes on it and I just
you know growing up my older brother's
yielded brothers y'all think they're
super cool right and they liked hot rod
cars from the 60s there was a lot of Big
Daddy Roth art or custom car culture was
really big and ever heard of Rat Fink or
yeah drawings were like it'd be like a
57 Chevy drum just doing a wheelie and
it's curved the back wheels really big
and the demon driving with a shifter and
his tongue hanging out and and that
makes an impact on you when you're young
about like like something happens to you
I think when you're like eight or
something we're like you just impact on
what it's cool and I think that always
made a big strong impression on me yeah
and so I can't help with like hot rods
and this is this had the most heavy
metal soundtrack that I'd ever heard in
the game yeah point you know
we tried to license like we didn't know
what we're gonna do with music because
it felt like our own like our MIDI thing
might not cut it but we hadn't done a
lot of digital music but we went had a
meeting with the record company that had
Soundgarden is an idea yeah had a song
called kickstand and the site was called
the kickstand and so gasm but that
didn't go that way when they found out
what her budget was which was nothing
yeah I mean this was this was earlier
and you said 1995 so then what was the
woman to come out after this that you
worked on great finding Grim Fandango
so after this one was tumors there was
someone like the dead things gonna be
great yeah and you know everything were
some talk about 3ds which is really
fancy back then yeah so like some of the
bikes you notice that we because we had
our vehicles and they were gonna rotate
instead of painting all those frames a
hand there we like let's make him in
three dimensions and rotate him around
so I was very excited but we still just
model them all what rendered them and
then painted every single frame so it
wasn't like really 3d yeah like CGI in
this game at all
and then grim was was through well it
was true 3d for the character Jeremy on
screen I want to know who when you said
you want you kind of were walking that
tightrope right between preserving the
password but also updating it enough for
modern palates what else beside the
visuals did you work on if anything like
on the service level yeah you seemed so
excited about the pre mixing remastering
the audio both the music and the sound
effects and the digital music and stuff
using samples of the better samples now
and then the visuals we have we added we
went up to the Skywalker Ranch where
they saw the archive of all the actual
painted like we're still doing stuff on
on paper it's creating it back then so
we found all the flat files ahead all
here so we scanned it and you can see
it's in the concept art you can see how
close it was to that's that one's even
making the game but there's the original
kickstand and easy old Peter Chan art
and then a lot of a lot of studies of
you can kind of see the story of how we
and you know with her a lot of different
iterations of what men should look like
yeah so yeah you can see all the really
rough sketches and variants and the
different style and this is all right
LucasArts stuff is up at Skywalker Ranch
yeah this is like humidity controlled
right warehouse next to the dailies from
Empire Strikes Back inside yeah yeah
that's awesome so it's nicer they they
really you know think part of the Lucas
world they really care about
preservation yeah like so preservation
game preservation paint Ben and guy
brush and everyone yeah
and so we had that and then also you can
see the boats features here there's a
two boxes to the music there's concept
artists there's also audio audio
commentary we had kind of a um well mini
reunion of the team Rob that people I
hadn't seen in years
yeah it sat in the room we watched the
game we talked and told stories and they
remembered things about the gift I don't
I don't know her at all but it was great
that we could share all that because I
think but you know when you want to play
a little game cousin IDs for whatever
reason there are fan fans have done
amazing job keeping that stuff alive
yeah and they make this like the scummvm
is one of the engines that players came
up with themselves so they could run old
games or any computers and they do a ton
of stuff that we really appreciate it
had integrated sometimes into our
remasters play the thing they can't do
is to provide a kind of art inconstant
the context of when that game was made
what were the context was around it who
the people were what they wanted to do
you know seeing that concept right you
kind of see what they want make the game
look like right different one also the
commentary is like we can explain like
what we were thinking them so it's it
feels like a great time to do this
because we've instilled while looking
we're still alive but you know I can go
on forever yeah I mean it hopefully was
a little bit okay but we like when we
were ripping stuff off the
reel-to-reel tapes and stuff I felt like
this is the last time that tape is gonna
work it's my pee this thing is crumbling
to dust everybody does it
so it was kind of like a last chance did
I grab some of those assets sure you can
see some of the commentary going on
right now talking about puzzles that we
cut and stuff like that stories that can
be told now that years have passed
yeah that's awesome statute of
limitations as fast money but somebody
right right yeah how much of that I mean
so the first one to remaster before Grim
Fandango was
all right it was grim fandago than data
tentacle and then now this right look so
every the ones you've remastered from
like weedy grim and then we did a Nicole
and now we get this right okay yeah I
was wondering I was kind of curious what
that's like without rights from
LucasArts stuff well I mean it's
complicated as big companies evolved and
what helped a lot was that they're just
people at both companies who were fans
of the genre
you know they and they have this mantra
that kept saying like you won't do the
right things by the fans the players
which is to bring those back and I know
big companies can be tricky but if you
have they're just still in the mitt of
individuals and you find that passionate
like game player in a company and make
decisions happen yes another talk about
Sierra games in chess we played Sarah
yes yeah yeah we played them in softball
they can talk about the ranch we had a
softball match with them and until they
kicked our ass and Bandung they're in
there like newsletter they sent to their
fans we just had a picture of their team
and it said Sarah beats competitor in
cell phone I could be mixing our names
yeah it's interesting to see between the
interest in the remasters and you know
stuff like the sierra or releasing stuff
regionally it's kind of interesting to
see that people are kind of back into
this genre lately and then you have you
know like why don't I think else in
Boyde Park yeah yeah art from Ron
Gilbert right he just released that yeah
and that's that to really kind of
capture the look of me in action
Brendon so I I mean it's nice the way
things have changed in the world with
digital distribution and crowdfunding
and all these different things what it
means is that you used to have to be
really really big to get out there you
saturate a guaranteed hit but now if you
just have it an audience that you can
reach and crowdfunding helps you reach
that audience get organized the money to
fund the thing you're making and then
digital distribution less you meet me a
social media lets you like get all those
people so things like adventure games
we're never gonna be as big as first
shooters or some other genre can still
exist they don't have to go away because
they have their audience they have their
dedicated audience who will always want
to play them and so they're possible now
and people are revisiting them and they
it doesn't it doesn't have to be like
one genre or two genres to take over and
that's all the games industry makes
anymore people share their micro manage
audiences right because just stuff like
in parsnip stems are coming back to it
stuff there are teams doing any like
System Shock 3 and the System Shock
remaster and all those kind of things
and even like what full right companies
do and what they're kind of like almost
like 3d take on adventure games in a way
those narrative simulators seems like
you know with so many different
audiences so many ways to reach those
audiences so many different kinds of
games are being you know created and of
great quality too and it's really
awesome to see we're talking about how
we were Joe's full screen animation just
to save time cuz like something if you
if you have a wide shot if a character
walking on the screen getting on a bike
and riding out that's like a nation but
if you cut to like yeah and cut to his
bike tilting a little bit and then cut
to the eyes but those goggles you can
like do a few cuts they're like save on
the animation but it also seems a little
bit cooler that's always fascinating to
hear how game is the like a style
developed because of technical
limitations like resident evil which was
one that pops out in my head right the
the fixed camera became a thing that
they did and then even like earlier Tony
Hawk games to like look like they were
actually moving through a 3d environment
but not really that's always fascinating
to me I remember
well maybe I'm thinking cuz swear I was
like a bat like the backgrounds actually
no no okay I'm confusing you know could
be and
yeah those little games it inspired us a
lot we're out of this world
we played down the squirrel door out of
the world in new Europe and he's cool
I've heard of it yeah it's a game that
uses a really low five poly look for the
intro cutscene had this it like it look
a little finer we've been had is like
luc besson style
cinnamon like the story was really well
storyboarding so they got the scene of a
guy going through an elevator is just
like a slit and milski with a light
moving up it you're like oh yeah and the
thing that it just was really inspiring
that you don't have to like show a
detailed animation all the time just had
a nice cut that helps you save a lot of
animation so it looks really super
French double find new wave cinema yeah
exactly
full throttle super French the most
French game it's my office here smo
maureen from she fixes your bike that's
the pop-up cursor we did a big there's a
big change for this game because we use
have the verbs and look at the look down
and look up and look down look up I wish
the cursors I wish the verbs are right
where your cursor is oh right so we have
a pop up cursor and we were just trying
to move the obstacles to playing playing
a game because um their game later on my
crimp he's like mario 64 come out and
you could just push in the direction you
wanted to go like it's hard to remember
that was such an innovative idea like
because resident evil because of the
different camera cuts like I think that
was that was take controls yeah sure I'm
you just go left right and go forward be
confusing as hell I mean I remember the
the first god of war felt like the first
game that really figured out how to
maintain that direction when it did
switch cameras even though it was like
fully 3d to solder double major I think
it would like as you joke to the camera
it would maintain your attention if you
let go the stick or like if you're
climbing up
how are the conversation about those
kind of control issues yeah you don't
maybe you notice them when you're
playing unless they are dumb and they
don't work yeah but after Mario 64 just
like yeah you push the direction you
want to go that's it the heavens look
like we should try and make it mention
hands more they're just easy easy to
move because that's not the interesting
thing figure out how to walk from one
room to
not the interesting part the interesting
part is like what item do I use on what
item when how do I solve this puzzle I
didn't see that car heading down that
did you Ben say like the town is sinking
they're in a storytelling environmental
storytelling they're a precursor and he
said some of the chat feels old trust me
I'm older uh yeah for those just joining
we do have the YouTube twitch and
GameSpot chats up right next to our feed
so uh get into a Q&A when we're done a
kind of showing a little more the game
at but uh feel free to shoot questions
our way right now it was another great
Mark Hamill piece he did three parts in
the game nore camel what cuz he had
already become the Joker on the animated
series back in ninety four or five and
we got him to do maybe through our Lucas
connections gotten to through three
parts he does em at the truck driver
Todd the junkyard sculpture and also
obviously a better arch doing was that
something like he was he into games ro
and then approach though he starts about
doing that stuff where was advice
personally we went out to him because we
were talking about what voice would be
perfect for wherever you know everyone's
really got just dripping with evil yet
Mark's got a really evil voice yeah
doesn't come true in Star Wars that much
right you were evil that was the most
alluring aspect at first for Arkham
Asylum
nobody was reprising in stroker role for
those games I was great
it's super nice to work with two super
didn't show the animation you being back
whole sound effect right
I don't member the joke with that line
you defines true beauty I feel like that
was a reference to referencing that's
one thing that was well I lost the
secret door
spoiler nice don't watch too much of
this you guys
[Music]
[Applause]
I asked some of those Sebastian Scholes
and the YouTube chat was just asking
with a rough estimation for the PS Vita
release that would be same day April 18
April at ps4 and PC yeah it's actually a
great way to play on the Vita because
you can use this stick all of our
adventure games on the Vita you know you
can write cycle and less cycle through
all the inventory on the cursor and you
can use the sticks if you want you can
use the right stick to hop between hot
objects but also you just touch the
screen and really like point your
adventure it you beyond just looked up
that way and so it's it's one of the you
know being a combination machine to
touch screen yeah that stick that's
really fun way to plan chroma Travis in
the twitch chat we're just asking you if
you have a personal LucasArts adventure
game how am I gonna pick Doug's taking
Sony this one this one this is the one
pre-order right now on the PlayStation
Store and steam to try to pick a like a
favorite child this is a button they're
all they're all so different you know
the first woman lucky island that worked
on it's like really hard to leave the
memories of that I mean me that at
Skywalker Ranch it's all tied to might
like personal memories of it
David tentacle was once referred to as
the last like easy time we had make a
game cuz we didn't have yeah
3d art you didn't have voice acting we
didn't have to worry about Musa it was
very manageable game just games just
ramped up with complexity after you know
I'm around 95 and it's never stopped
going this you know super super complex
huge huge team probably a kind of
intimidating thing to take on as your
first lead like reading your first
project right I mean between voice
acting between kind of you know like you
just said 95 something a lot of things
are ramping up must have been kind of a
hectic we've got pretty hectic you know
you kind of ease into it it was mostly
just like had idea like how this should
work and want to tell a story a certain
way a certain feeling to it here you
know and their love I remember some of
the influences there's like besides out
of this world as also an flux was a part
of the MTV animation yes there's like
the idea of doing stylized art with
having it not be for little kids don't
stylize art
also Mike Mignola's Hellboy I think was
a good influence on like a lot of the
dark silhouette shapes to see in a lot
of places but I really like and this is
the first game we were trying to push it
has a the puzzles being you know we were
like we don't like games where the
puzzles are just like let's put let's
fill your inventory with a hundred
objects and you have to find out which
objects to use through those and we're
like let's not there's only have like
six things max in your maggiore
and you have to figure out you know what
the context of when to use those objects
so it's simplified like this puzzle here
there's really everything you need is
almost on the screen of this de-pants
chain and you gotta figure out how to
work it so that you can get into the
junkyard I like this animation well use
your foot on it use your foot on it
little-known yeah that's my favorite
animation the game probably no one finds
that one and wiggling his boot and
wheeling his boot in the biker fashion
it's very common yes that was in the
pine rest Thomson book yeah foot Wiggles
tail points notorious for it ballerina
kicks back in this junky old town and
they still paint the curb red there cuz
I don't part and we got to get the truck
from junkyard even though the whole town
sunk in the mud that's great yeah for
those just joining Greg would you be
able to switch back to the old style
really quick so yeah it's like those
just joining like we mentioned earlier
in the stream
you can widget no you squid looks
alright you can switch between these on
the fly if you want a more nostalgic
look you can stick with that but yeah or
you can just update it I'm really torn
Bosley though the old one for me like it
brings back these memories of like
remember the first time plated or
whatever you're working on it every
pixel has a sweet memory to it but like
I'm cuz you stare at him so much like
his faces made it was such a small
amount of pixels at Maureen's face that
her eyes are like three pixels and
mouths a two and then when you go back
to the
it's like yeah that's how they look at
my head looks more of a like a five
o'clock shadow on his face rather than
just a great face I love that like the
universal d-pad design huh Larry here
just felt kneepads were important to
biker culture probably was rolling down
the asphalt you ride a motorcycle and I
did in college I had a little Honda that
ride to class on but I never had a
really big like ever had a been throttle
bike did you know I was considering
getting my motorcycle license like last
year but I put it off but my brother
like I said my brother's had them and
they improved it that's cool yeah tons
of pipes for training out of it I think
to be surrounded by metal in the car
trust me game yeah I there were these
two roommates who live down the hall
from me in college named marina and Tina
and this oh I had the original stories
about these twins named marina Tina who
were there's gonna be like a twin
swapping story proper story going on
with them and then we I got cutting some
characters let's cut Tina's so we cut
Tina sorry Tina
only Maureen lasted damn we're tensions
high on the or no that was probably
afterward but the chief account thank
you saying why the hell did you cut me
no no no girls of my high school my
college dorm have not kept my facebook
page sadly oddly enough in a bizarre
twist
yeah YouTube yeah yeah calm birch I'm
probably butchering that he's asking if
there's a chance for maniac mansion
remake or a seer band there's always a
chance of two things happen for any of
these games is like you want if the
original creator wants to be involved
like it Ron Gilbert wanted to be
involved with that we would be into
doing it or if how bar would want to be
involved in indie or you know or steep
yourself or Sam axe the you know those
original creators thought it was a cool
idea to remaster he wanted to do the
commentary that's the only reason I
think we should do it but also you know
the rights are are complicated so we'd
have to be able to get those rights yeah
so I think it also would be a great idea
you know these we've done now that this
is the last of the games that were had
my name on them but there's still a lot
of great adventure games yeah every
subsequent game you worked on was uh was
every subsequent game you worked on from
Double Fine
after grim after grim okay right yeah
then you started with Psychonauts do
them much from there I hope more people
didn't remasters like I liked it I just
think the cuz some other people have
brought back other people's games as
like a third party I think just because
they wanted them to be playable again
sure but I wish more original creators
would remaster them so they can kind of
keep them true to what they do visually
yeah from a personal standpoint is
probably cooler gonna go back to your
roots a little bit right yeah sure I
mean I think it's interesting we've
visited something you made in 20 years
we don't think about what you do now
what you did then and you know how
you've changed and definitely the
writing and you know you know the
writing the dialogue is not a different
style but like it feels different to me
but shares like in my twenties when I
wrote some lines and I wrote lines about
topics I didn't really understand then
and then and that's right now I'm older
oh yeah yeah you look at something like
broken age and it's a very different
tone right but I think that's indicative
of where you were when you like we're
working on they're like here I wrote all
this before my years spent in a
Louisiana prison or so I didn't know
much about these guards these southern
guards back
but now I do know I didn't never been in
prison Louisiana I was gonna let you
clarify was a joke know why they have
southern accents in this crazy world
they're the only people in the game that
have this like combat here
that's your understanding of the south
at the time then only the cops are
southern it just felt like more Dukes
Hazzard that way I guess
there's one question about where we
found the extra art for the HD for that
most of you most of orkut seems like
every scene in the can't wait actually
we go back to the old can't go back to
the retro art maybe this one day yeah I
guess we did yeah it was a lot more
extra painting we had to do we had the
extra concentration pH and would always
paint extra but was more rough of us
detailed mostly for the color bleed and
stuff you would paint a little area and
we had that original art and then the
artist actually also would use creative
license and doing that cool yeah there's
people ask me what my trophies
technically yes they'll be trophies oh
yeah I assume we've gotten them didn't
get a platinum yeah give any saying
going back and deciding what those are
we ready we read the achievements yeah
and we're the trophy okay did they set
you the rules about like how many points
you get like those bronze silver you can
apply them this yeah but I can get a
list of all the trophies and how to beat
them so vanish don't think I don't do
that
are you a trophy fiend Achievement
Hunter no well that certain game seven
games you just feel like I need to I
mean this game I've been doing I kind of
write yeah well the opposite of that I
kind of wanna do with persona 5 which is
not isn't short it's I don't have the
time and like but I'll try elect grab
every single thing that you can
everywhere and do this every person
already crazy yeah thank you
yeah coughs rich avoid some that right
yeah close Jeannie melty you should be
able to kick it down that's true I know
that bootlegging screw up a mailbox
that's my favorite line in the game cuz
you hear it so much I had to make it my
favorite
that should have no we should have had
the game end with you kissing Maureen
I'm saying I'm gonna provide live
something doesn't happen that way you
guys I don't think there's not a
foreshadow cool I don't know I mean we
can keep going unless you want to get
right into a Q&A if you don't wanna
spoil too much in the game for people
watching yeah cool questions alright
cool yeah we got a few compiled John
Luke in the back room can pull some up
but yeah everybody if you're just
joining I'm here with Tim Schafer of
Double Fine productions of course we
were just playing full throttle remaster
which will release on ps4 PS Vita and PC
on April 18th but we do have about
another 15 ish minutes on the stream and
we did have a few questions via Twitter
but we also have the twitch and YouTube
and GameSpot chest up here next to the
TV and we can reference those so if you
have any questions about full-throttle
remaster or other double science stuff
going on motorcycle maintenance exactly
yeah only ones with a lot of pipes
though yeah if it's not running at a
pipe and just see what happened and if
it doesn't work just keep going yeah
more pipes cool yeah so John Luke you
want to pull up that first question that
we gathered from Twitter here we go from
Tim Collins what is your favorite puzzle
in the game if you have one that's like
a three-part question can you call if
you have a favorite puzzle do you have
well I really that junkyard I have fond
memories of that junk yard gate puzzle
just because it was this moment where I
like realizing we don't need to have a
complicated inventory for the puzzle we
could just have it be maybe one
inventory item and you have to figure
out some combination of that doors
anyway because I it was it was the birth
of like a new way of looking at puzzle
design for me and so I really I like
that oh cool
yes that's Tim Collins on Twitter thank
you for your like directing voice yeah
yeah gentleman put that back up it was
like three parts I would just say thanks
Tamlyn Neely Oh actually directed the
voice acting and the sound Department
all said Chris Brown it who we still
work today doing your own voice and we
did go down for one day and got two four
for Mark Hamill got two
we're gonna Amman and he was obviously
Brees because marks a total pro and had
been doing Bo stuff for a long time yeah
it was super fun also do you wish you
had a more searchable name somebody
tells me you might not have been worried
about like SEO at the back then there
was no drink there's no energy drink
called full throttle oh thank you
that's probably means and Charlie's
Angels - that was a there's and also
there's another thing no searching
there's no inner yeah yeah you were you
were at the forefront mean 95 it was
like I think we would get feedback on
this game from coffee serve okay so I
think that's that was the the most of
that beer so you were a full throttle
pioneer yeah so I'm just waiting for all
those things to come out so that we can
obviously just sue them all on one yeah
like Charlie's Angels get them all in
one big lawsuit now you just have some
yeah lawsuit sponsorships if you bought
probably in settlements and won the hope
that's my retirement plan
Tim Collins thank you very much for your
question I got a couple more we can pull
up here from actually day would you
consider remastering an adventure you
didn't originally work on and if so
which of your favorites which one would
that be yeah I mean I am I would like I
was saying I would love to do it as long
as we could have a great interaction
with original creators and have them do
you know do you have any concept art and
your hard drive like get those those
assets in might have them there are
ideas for the commentary that would be
great and I think you know obviously a
lot of the old LucasArts wants to be
great to do like Santa max and curse of
McAllen and and Indiana Jones but yeah
who knows but no as soon as you get
rights there I don't know this Harrison
Ford has to prove that oh well now
you've got Kingdom of the Crystal Skull
to work with - right it's a lot of
options that we were made an adventure
game of that one though um yeah we
you're right we could unit rate skulls
into it attacking a movie like that and
then I mean for other companies I mean I
loved I text adventures but I don't know
about remastering a text adventure but I
used to love all those infocomm games
you know challenge right cool Ashley Day
thank you so much for question here we
got one more I think
do you ever see a full-throttle brutal
legend crossover interesting how do you
know they're not I mean one's basically
a sequel hey I'm gonna cover that
but a shared universe guarantee oh yeah
brutal legend everything we did imply
that that Ben and hoagies the devil are
brothers
cuz they make a joke about their mom
that I was fighting to name them both
that your sandwiches
his name was full names Reuben small
small little facts fun fact just for the
game spots room that's the sandwich
Easter Egg of the day who cool
don't tell anyone you guys cool you I am
wearing a flame and Fletcher I got from
the molasses flood nice you're helping
is that was second that's uh was it I
could be mistaken this did Scott
Sinclair work on that yeah yeah I talked
to him a few times yeah dad about other
stuff he did back with irrational you
use that irrational yeah they did
flaming the flow which is really fun
really hard survival game yeah
and they helped us with our prototype
four seconds to oak or doing is that we
did a video about it looks beautiful and
I got a t-shirt out of it so how nice I
so here we have the live chats here sir
what what's gaming on YouTube was asking
a topical question is there a chance to
be releasing any classics for the switch
I like to switch a lot I like I'm really
deep in Zelda right now yeah really
focusing on these platforms right now
for this projects we've got a lot of
help from Sony to get them made you know
probably wouldn't happen without this
yeah so that's probably where they're
gonna live cool huh yeah and then Ruru
rook on twitch was asking what do you
think of the potential for adventure
games in VR between like you just had
rhombus of ruined yeah we they went on
yeah we made uh we didn't realize we're
making one for a while we were just you
know think about the interactions you
could have in VR cuz we didn't want to
move around a lot because you just get
sick yeah and I just noticed this desk
is a big controller I'm just sorry I
just spotted the hope from above yeah
yeah yeah have little trays with the
sorry analogues for coffee I apologize I
just notice I just now you guys I think
can't even see that on the camera I just
noticed the the sandwich joke in that
game so trade it off so yeah we are so
you realized that your instead of
pointing click you're kind of gazing and
clicking cuz you're using your psychic
powers so rums room is on
psvr now and and and after we're
finished were like we just made an ID so
after broken age I was like okay that's
enough of it against for a while because
I remembered how hard they are to make
they're very you make a lot of you put a
lot of work into a specific interaction
that the player might buzz through in 15
minutes and if I kind of took us months
to make words another game might make a
system and then you explore that system
for hours but compared that you know so
I'm and then immediately we went to work
on another adventure game and we made
Ramos a ruin which but it was really fun
it's still really fun too this is more
physical adventure or you could like TK
that tell it use telekinesis to pick up
that Cup and move it and turn it around
and put it in the right place to solve a
puzzle and then burn something to solve
a puzzle okay use your psychic powers so
second powers are a great way to use you
know they're fun verbs to use verbs in
the VR world yeah you could oh yeah we
do that again cool I probably get less
one last question here Chronos 914 on
the twitch chat was asking the comparing
which of our arms are hairier oh oh no I
think they're commenting on mine I am
working on a tattoo and I you know they
had to do this stream that's for more
long sleeve shirts no no no valuable
airtime yeah content yeah there we go
what we gonna do surprise because it's a
full-throttle that it is yeah it's gonna
wall it's gonna be good for the legend
on the killers we had it done for this
you're like by the way just like one
last night for 12 hours to finish it but
yeah my data technical tattoo is in work
next year I'll get to work on that yeah
cool
we got ya Kronos 914 to twitch I was
asking how are like I was working on
like creating puzzles and games
different that it used to be if it is I
mean like I know do you find audiences
are more sophisticated and how they're
solving puzzles
I mean it's somebody's a lot more
impatient I think people don't you know
you when you had one game you'd play
awesome along because you're stuck at
your grandparents on so ever like in the
90s like you you'd really milk her game
for a long time you would expect it to
take a long time dedicate a lot of time
to it
and nowadays are so many games coming
out every single day it's like you've
got I gotta finish this in three days
cuz like horizons coming out or like you
know something's think you know you
gotta keep moving
so when people get stuck they're just
like I'm not gonna waste my night on one
puzzle and they're just like look it up
on the internet right away so you kind
of have to work with that in some ways
we just work with it we've spent a lot
more time on plate testing so you watch
people play the game over and over and
over again I was really impressed with
the bimbo playing limbo cuz every time I
was just about to throw my controller
and anger I couldn't solve a puzzle I'm
in limbo I would get it that's crazy
and I admit the guys who played and once
I asked them how they did that they're
like we just spent years watching people
play the game and making small
adjustments yeah when you talk to the
people like no we don't talk to them
just bring him in and we watch them play
and that's me so I think that's because
you can theoretically be like this is a
hard puzzle this is an easy puzzle I
think they'll be stuck I think they'll
get it and you can debate back and forth
like they'll get it because we put the
sandwich there obviously think and then
you just put some in front of it and
they don't even see the sandwich and and
you watch the game with the cursor
you'll watch like you really want them
to pick up the remote and you'll watch
the cursor move around the remote and go
towards it and go over here and they
like just click clean they'll go over
here and it's maddening to so they'd add
a spotlight on it you test it again and
then you change one little thing you
test it again and that's that's that's
what's like nowadays to do did you play
out inside last year mm-hmm yeah it was
great and then the witness speaking of
games and I just when I thought I
couldn't solve a puzzle mm-hmm usually
but also I sometimes did intelligence
yeah oh I think it's all the time we had
today uh tim schafer thank you so much
for coming thank you for having me thank
you for playing the game thanks for
watching and asking questions in the
chat yeah yeah Greg rice from Double
Fine's is also back there thanks for
playing the game Greg and for those who
don't know
full throttle remastered will be out on
April 18th for PlayStation 4 PlayStation
Vita and PC I'm looking forward to it
awesome and we'll see you around we got
you three coming up I'm sure we'll
hopefully run into you there yeah yeah
Kuwait's the plane goes yeah see you
guys later
[Music]
[Applause]